[Music]
Samuel let's say welcome to winners on a
Wednesday this week we have a fantastic
winner we have Raheem hello summer night
nice to meet you good show you on the
show all the way from Sierra Leone you
move down to England when you were 15
yes with absolutely nothing we're now
financially free yes high five bro
in your 20s 27 27 correct it all started
when you read my book by low rate high
correct
tell us the story and basically I was
searching in the internet to understand
about properties wanted to know about
property then wonderful videos came up
I'd had listened to it to the video to
understand what you're talking about and
then all of a sudden I heard about your
book which I then ordered online I think
I remember if I did it free or I paid
probably free prose yeah I think I just
say one thing you achieve financial
freedom I knew now making how much you
like seventeen yeah I'm making about
seven grand a month
yes starting we started with nothing
correct and in order to get to there yes
from me you got a free book no free
YouTube videos yes and a free two-day
crash course yes actually what I did
when I bought that book it wasn't enough
for me I had to pay the audio Odyssey as
well I listened to it over and over and
over if you go to my car right now
that's what I play I went out when I
came to the course that we're doing
right now as well as when I go back home
so obviously that has helped me greatly
especially the templates you had there
about how to secure no money down there
so I literally memorize I know exactly
exactly everything what I see so cool
you probably know the book better than I
know the book now right so so you bought
the book when did you when did you
purchase the book boy that went I would
say I bought the book in August last
year this year this year
yeah so you bought walk in August before
that you were watching all of my you
know I was watching all your YouTube
videos trying to understand but you were
too good to be true to be honest with
you but then when I realize that what
you're doing is actually real and you
are you are doing what you're saying as
well as the time I started I then
registered to you I just subscribe to
your YouTube channel so I understand
what you're the full of your journey for
about a week or so then I bought the
book then I bought the CD then I said
definitely I'm gonna tell wonderful
crash course that's so cool and you and
you tell you that
let's rewind because right now you're
doing really well you're making seven
thousand pounds a month now you've got a
rent to rent business you started from
nothing I want you to tell us the story
of how you did that right I want to
start by you telling I want to know a
little about your background so tell us
tell us a bit about I know you're not
from a wealthy background at all yes of
course um I'm from Sierra Leone I would
say Guinea as well because one of my
parents are from Guinea moved to the UK
age of 15 without my parents so I have
without a parent without my parents so
you need to 15 who was looking after you
I was looked after by cost of actually
so well I grew up in London where there
was lots of crime so I was able to do
stuff to distract myself from involving
in all those kind of crimes I was able
to go to college then move on to
universities I did a degree on
accounting finance then walked as an
accountant that's impressive
going from going from coming down 15
with no parents in foster care to then
going going to university is a massive
massive achievement thank you
so I mean massive achievement thank you
so I mean what was the what was the
lowest point for you as a teenager when
were you the most kind of lost if you
like is when I was in school and when we
had parent meetings and I had to have my
foster family to come round up my real
family it was one of my lowest point but
at the same time motivates me because
they were there for me do you still
speak to your parents yes I do now and
then yes I do call them talk to them
sometimes so yes I still have and you
still speak of your foster parents yes
of course of course she's my mom
basically because she brought me up in a
wave a kid very very interesting
background so I mean it's easy sometimes
people say I bring people on the show
and they say oh it was easy for you or
you know your parents gave you money or
your but you your parents are only
they're not giving you money that they
couldn't even look after you as a
teenager
no no so yes and when I moved to I used
to work in the city as well for a year
so I moved to Cardiff Bay and because of
what part it is because of a job
basically I moved there because the
company was migrating to Belgium
Brussels yeah my decide I did not want
to go to Brussels then I read a stay in
the UK a London was too busy to me also
a thought problem maybe not be able to
achieve my potential in London because I
got family and friends around so of a
problem if I move out out of London
again refresh reflect myself and so now
you've got a good job you're qualified
as an accountant and you're living in
Cardiff yes what was your income what
were you making as an accountant well
that's an accountant I was earning about
thirty thousand pounds a year brilliant
right and for a start but I thought all
the time that I needed lots of money to
get into property until I saw your
videos so you'll make a 30 grand a year
and you wanted you had a desire to get
out of that when going to property but
you thought you needed loads of money
correct and and and you what why did you
want to get into property at all because
I want to be financially free I like to
do to not to be told what to do
basically and also I wanted to find a
way that would be financially free
before I am safe to you as always have I
achieved now yes I think it's it's a
brilliant brilliant thing to do then
because obviously only took me about a
year so when you were working for
someone else I mean did you enjoy being
an accountant or not when I started yes
I enjoyed it but then they just become
boring and also I'd not like to be told
what to do yes I've told you and I just
wanted to be independent really you've
also got a massive heart
Yona you're very very you were very
drawn to some of our charitable projects
you want to come out to Africa you want
to help out of the charitable project
yeah and I assume that was a big reason
for you in wanting to become financially
independent as well right right yes yeah
yes that is one of my reason because
that's the reason why I really wanted to
meet you in person so I because I
believe we can work together in a way
supporting charities as well as in a
business sense because I believe giving
back to community I started that since I
was young as one also tends to be you've
invested in Croydon and represent wow
I'm young you are a nice human being so
yes I believe in that's one of the
reason why I really wanted to work with
you so we can help our community better
that's in quick you you're all inspired
you and you inspire me bro antastic you
really inspire me bro and I'm just so
glad to just
you know begin to build a friendship
with you now and I thank you you came to
the crash course in August right I'm
sorry September and that was this year
yes and that's insane that was like two
months ago correct and you man what
happened at the crash course well I went
to the crash course from a
recommendation from a friend of mine and
voted because again this is a pattern
here Windows on a Wednesday
you saw Paul an an on winners on a
Wednesday right did you doubt that did
you doubt their store did you think it
might be fake no you know I know it was
a hundred percent true because I've met
them and they've told me what they were
doing now let them but when you first
watch them were you less suspicious I
was a bit suspicious because it was a
bit too good to be true yeah the thing
is people will be watching this right
now yeah and they'll be suspicious of
you
of course and they'll probably reach out
to you yeah in the same way that you
reached out to Paul around right yes
it's just a rippling effect of good I
inspires someone they then go and
produce an electrifying amazing story
which then inspires someone else you
know which has a rippling effect yes
which is why I just love doing this yes
exactly so thank you enough basically
because if I had to meet you I wouldn't
have the motivation and the hunger yeah
to move on because since of winter crash
was in September I was able to close
about six things actually from the crash
course from the crash course I was able
to what kind of deals with them there
were four rental rent deals and they're
making me 700 pounds a month
Wow net each so you came on the crush
course there's a free crash course yes
of course it you've got six deals yes
you had no money yes
four of them were rent to rent correct
and they were making you set and they're
just HMOs in Cardiff truly hurt you're
fully licensed for five years as well so
I don't even have to pay for this or
more license and then they can you 507 H
what were the other two deals yeah yeah
there were two deals are buy-to-let
deals and again how did you get the
finance good question so what happened
was I had a property that I bought not
long ago I used that as a well I used my
rental rent cash flow the money I've
already
than my rent to rent yeah to put for one
of the deals down so you found two deals
on the crash course that were by two
let's four deals that were meant to
rents the cash flow from the rent to
rents you put an apartment you use that
towards the deposit correct that's
exactly what I did and yes and and the
other property what I did was it's a
more no money down deal basically I had
a property yeah I'm using bridging yeah
to fund until hundred percent so
basically I'm not gonna put any money in
it apart from the refurbishment this
this is too good to be true charming
slide this is incredible how did you
what did you learn at the crash course
that enabled you to go and find six
deals what I've learnt was no matter who
you are if you're hard working and
you've been guided you you can do what
you want to do in life is all on you I
believe in working hard and then your
luck would come yeah so basically after
the kruskal's I work twice as hard just
to see if I can get these deals and then
it happens I said I set a target our
ladies to see I would have at least six
deals yeah end of the year
thankfully I am in the progress of you
now you've now quit your job yes of
course I did quit it I have to to mines
but I thought probably the best to quit
because I think if I quit I'll be able
to do so many stuff yeah and I'll be
able to learn and empower myself now
you're financially free you've quit your
job you're making seven thousand pounds
residual income every single month
correct what passive yes have you
systemized your regiment business
I'm trying to systemize it and this is
where you come in that's the reason why
I like to work with you because you've
got experience you've got knowledge and
you've got you know how when is you've
come back now and you've said to me
you've said to me I mean just today and
you said look dude I read your book I
listened to it an audible over and over
and over I count you free crash course I
watch all YouTube videos I'm now
financially free I'm making seven grand
Imam I've quit my job can we do
something else kind of like kind of
thing can we move you little can I help
you with your charity stuff can I help
you what's next yes and now we're
talking about whelming we've got
friendship now we're talking about news
and charges stuff together right you're
here sat on the show and I'm gonna help
you because you're such an amazing
Thank You systemize the business okay
because at the moment you're making very
good money right but you're still having
to kind of keep an eye on it yes of
course you couldn't leave the country
for six months no I can't
you've got a key so the next stage is
going to be to really system ones that
so it's completely passive correct right
okay I mean another thing I'll say as
well is working hard is really good but
if you remember at the crash course and
in the book if you listen to it one of
the seven lies is that working hard
alone will make you rich you have to
work smart okay work with the right
knowledge right so what one piece of
knowledge would you give to someone who
was if you were speaking to your six
month ago self right right you're
speaking to yourself six months ago or a
year ago before you knew anything about
property what would be the best piece of
advice you could give yourself find
people like yourself that would have
guide me to get to where I am now I
believe if I had you in my life then I
would have been 1000% over what I would
have achieved 1,000% over whatever chief
right right now because I may have
learnt it the hard way but since I've
met ye it has accelerated my business
over fifty percent so imagine if I'd
known me for I say about three or six
months it would have been a lot better
that's good so basically just get the
right fine people but I've already done
it exactly and then copy them copy them
because it's school we're told not to
copy people we're told not to use a
calculator weight or not but in real
life you should copy people you should
use a calculator and still the answer
yes exactly and and and and the good
thing about you also you are so genuine
you don't hide stuff you tell people the
way it is yeah you're not gonna say okay
I'm just gonna show them a little bit of
something and so they can come to my
other courses you just tell them exactly
what you do and if you want to achieve
great things the people need to meet
people like you because you are opening
open and genuine to teach people and let
them know how they could achieve
independence as well as financial
freedom thank you so much for that have
you got any plans once you can take I
mean you've only been in the game not
too long but once you've started to
really build up a wealth part you got
any plans to perhaps do anything bigger
or maybe start buying building your own
portfolio or
yes I'm starting to build my own
portfolio now of course also you've got
two over there I've already got to go in
now I've got another one already yeah
less my residential property so
altogether probably four to five so I'm
looking to build that up
my future plans is to review see if we
can establish a lectin agency or a
sourcing agent working in Cardiff which
I believe we would be able to achieve
great deal in helping people around the
local community yeah that's awesome
how is your foster how do you foster mom
foster parents foster mom what does she
think of all this
well I only told them about this not
long ago she is absolutely amazed about
it she's so delighted and she's happy to
have been part of my life and she's
really grateful to am what I currently
do that's incredible does it feel really
nice to have achieved such success from
such a misfortunate situation like ten
years ago
your life was completely completely
different how does it feel
you smell pinch yourself it feels
absolutely amazing sometimes if I paint
myself I don't even feel it because it's
just unbelievable and from where you
will start from to where you get Gutter
because you can meet lots of people
because when I sat down when I started I
was thinking how do I start this until I
seen your video I would have never known
where to go or what to do but now I've
watched a video I know it is doable and
your day as a great example so I believe
I can really really achieve big things
yeah and you know how I work you know
you make a move I make a move and you
have man you have making a hundred moves
I need to now make a thousand moves and
I cannot wait to work with you and to
really build something big together and
help you system wise that business I'm
so proud of you and I've really
appreciate you coming on the show oh
thanks very much thanks my name is
Samuel Leeds thank you for watching
winners on a Wednesday every single week
we interview a success students for your
inspiration you can watch more right
here on the playlist as a whole playlist
of them so what you'll notice is every
single winner on a Wednesday always
starts with them coming to my two day
crash course so if you would like to be
a winner on a Wednesday literally come
on my crash course and who knows in
three months time you could be here in
my offices on
show as a winner on a Wednesday so get
yourself booked on the crash course
watch more have fun I'll see you next
week